hello and welcome again to another
edition of The Gadget Lab podcast
I am Michael colori I am Mike Isaac and
today we're going to talk about some new
news from Apple and the software realm
then we're going to actual news not not
a rumor not a rumor
real news it's not a rumor and then
we're going to a tumor then we're gonna
cut to Billy Brown who's going to show
us some badass knives and then we're
going to come back and show you - badass
phones and we're going to have a badass
off with our phones but first let's talk
about some news from Apple so something
happened right and everyone freaked out
they actually had they actually had a
release or a hint of a release right
like a developer release of their OS 10
software is that OS I'm sorry OS X
software 10 point sorry I always want to
say 10 because of the X I'm Romina Mac
OS yes is no longer Mac OS it is now
called OS X 10.7 or 8 I think this is 8
8 10.8 mountain lion mountain lion so we
have lion last year press X lion which
brought a lot of new sort of iOS e-type
behaviors to the desktop you know
basically what Apple's been doing over
the last year is they've been taking
their their tablet and phone operating
system and bringing the lessons learn
from that onto the desktop yeah it's
sort of a contentious move people aren't
necessarily thrilled with it some people
love it some people hate it some people
haven't even updated yet like me yes the
1.7 yeah I'm still on Snow Leopard yeah
I'm just old school what can I say
lion is cool though we have it here at
the office and of course I've played
with it a little bit and took me a while
to get used to some of the gestures
going back and forth three three fingers
and then up and down swimming and things
like that
I think I think that was the smart thing
to do was to do that first so that
everybody could take a longer time to
get used to it because the changes that
have come out this week are more along
app integration than they are about
about gestures so a lot of the apps that
exists as standalone apps on the tablet
and on the phone
things like messages the calendar those
I know that yep there's a Notification
Center just like there is on the phone
now on the desktop so a lot of those
things have made the jump to the desktop
and I think people are going to probably
find that to be a more seamless
experience especially considering it
uses iCloud to sync everything on the
back end see that's what I think is one
of the more interesting aspects there
pushing iCloud that much more right like
this hardware company is suddenly saying
hey we can actually do cloud services as
well right well I you know I wouldn't
consider Apple necessarily just a
hardware company we're gonna get
philosophical here yeah I would consist
oft where company I guess as well with
that with the with the yeah i OS and and
now yes x i think i think you know the
the redo of iOS sorry the read the redo
of mac OS x mac OS i don't even know
what name acronym soup so yeah yeah like
a decade ago when they redid everything
under unix um then they really became a
software powerhouse i think as far as
operating systems and intuitive
interfaces things like that and then the
iphone solidified that and now we're
seeing the natural extension of that
back into the desktop although a no
more acting anyway one the one point I
want to bring up though is that they're
super the social aspect right they are
they are still stuck with only Twitter
in terms of outside app integration for
like you can tweet your stuff or you
can't I mean the most conspicuous
absence is the lack of Facebook right
and no Google+ what do you know so it's
out now for developers and it'll be out
for consumers this summer and you can
read our full review by Christina
Bonnington on wired.com
probably in a week yeah midweek sweet
okay now we're going to go out to the
woods with Billy's gonna show us his
knives
so if you've got that Mayan calendar
sitting in your living room you know
we've got about 10 more months before
everything goes to hell so when all the
electricity is gone and we're fighting
for water and gasoline pretty much this
is going to be your only tool for
survival
this is Gerber gears Survival Series
parang
it comes with a full tang a 13 inch
curved blade and has really solid
construction with a rubberized grip so
if things get wet things not going to go
flying out of your hand the Survival
Series prank is my favorite blade
because the full tank construction gives
it a really even weight and a really
good swing feel so if a zombie comes up
on you you can really get right into his
guts so if you really need to do a lot
of damage or you just want to chop a lot
of wood the camp axe 2 is gonna be the
one for you it's got most of its 34
ounces in the head and it's lightweight
nylon handle means you're basically
power swinging it every single time
kind of like a front loaded softball bat
and the hammer on the back makes it a
really versatile camping tool this is
the Gator machete jr. it weighs about
fourteen point three ounces comes with a
nice saw in the back of the blade and
has a great Gator grip for use during
rain or any time it's wet the thing's
not gonna fly out here here it's
probably my least favorite out of the
three because the blade only goes right
into here in the handle and it's a
little wobbly and slight weight but it
feels a little flimsy but for 20 bucks
you're going to be getting a lot of
[Music]
so he went house on the coconuts but he
didn't kill any squirrels I wanted to
see him like boom dude I thought you
were like a vegetarian and some I'm a
vegetarian so he's allowed to do that -
oh yes squirrels are gills or something
they're there they're vermin
they eat through the cables the outside
your house they're stealing all my nuts
you are crazy so we're just talking
about fun let's talk about phones we've
got two Android devices both of them
have a weird interesting quirk that
seems out of touch with the times this
one is the Droid 4 it's it's got a
keyboard which was supposed to have gone
the way of the dodo after the iPhone and
things like that with more touchscreen
focused interfaces came in right but
there's still people that use
BlackBerry's out there there are still
people that that prefer the keyboards
and Droid motorola recognizes that right
and I mean like the enterprise you know
that hasn't gone away a lot of people
still use them and they still sort of I
think the people that got hooked on
BlackBerry's originally you know or
sidekicks work or the sidekick you know
they need their keyboards so this one
with thumb or thumb jockey so we call
via thumb jockeys so are you coming so
what do you think that is it do you type
on it is it easy is it yeah I mean it's
Lizzie it is very well constructed it is
probably the best physical keyboard that
they've that Motorola's made yet they
had this is a fourth iteration of the
Droid series right so it's a verizon
phone you know this is the Droid brand
but it actually they do the keyboard
very well it's easy to type it's I did
it really fast I did the the quick brown
fox jumps over the lazy dog sentence
right in like a matter of seconds that's
the you know I'm talking about yeah it's
like yeah it's the sentence that uses
every letter in the English language I
just thought it was a colorful sentence
no that's why they have it because he
uses every
every letter in the English off of it
got in yourself of it so it works the
only no ligatures you know but the only
quibble I have is that the keyboard is a
little bit off-center in order to kind
of have to do this yeah I mean basically
you move your thumbs like a millimeter
to the left on exception to the right so
just yeah no I mean it sounds stupid but
it actually made you notice it in your
thumb stretching when you're typing so
in all it's cool if I'm like a dude in a
suit that has important business
meetings or whatever to attend and I
need to respond to emails fast I think
this is a pretty nice phone I'm gonna
get the full review later I guess I
don't buy that argument no I think you
can type just as fast on a software
keyboard with prac I've heard that I
don't that icky I think that's total BS
man my fingers are too fat to really oh
you can do the swipe thing some people
can that's I'm getting a whole new
keyboard in and of itself well speaking
of thumb stretching we have this you're
attending in India my goodness look at
the size of it it's huge what the hell
is that
this is the Samsung Galaxy Note it have
phone it's a phone it's a it's like over
five inches 5.3 inches I think it's an
AMOLED screen
it's a you know brand new hardware all
the specs look awesome on paper the
screen is big and bright and beautiful
it's freaking massive is the thing I
look ridiculous 50 red it's it's
gigantic and it's really funny too
because like you know I pull this out
and I show it's people know like oh my
god what is that but if you like though
I mean I mean do you know okay it has a
stylus right so it has handwriting
recognition so you can take notes with
it you can write emails with it you can
write text messages okay you could
doodle on it so there's this this
function built into it's not big for the
sake of being big you actually right
this is my little notepad it's meant to
be a two-handed device with the pen and
the notepad you can use your finger
instead of the the stylus as well um and
it's not really that great as one
buzz uh you can yeah you can't like the
thumb stretching thing is really
annoying you can't really type with one
hand like this when you're writing you
know on the soft keyboard holding it
like this forget about it you have to
use two hands most people do anyway when
they're holding it in the in the what is
that landscape mode um the thing about
it that is interesting is that it is a
full feature and Android handset so it's
a phone but it's just gigantic yeah I
I've only used it for a day but I would
say it's too big I'm going to spend the
weekend with it and I'm gonna take notes
of it I'm going to bring it to the
grocery store and cross things off my
list and and hopefully not lose the
stylus and and then we will give you a
full review of this next week nice so we
have the Samsung Galaxy Note three
hundred bucks AT&T 4G device and it runs
not Ice Cream Sandwich yeah not the
latest version right probably
gingerbread I'm guessing and that is the
Motorola Droid 4 with the QWERTY
keyboard which is also 300 I think it's
I think it is 300 on on Verizon contract
and it also runs not Ice Cream Sandwich
yeah so these are supposed to have Ice
Cream Sandwich coming but that time line
is singing yeah exactly
soon to be determined soon island time
island time the most important part of
the podcast oh yes we have to giveaway
last week we showed off the element case
the vapor Pro case the fancy black ops
like you know hundred dollar case for
your iPhone actual nice iPhone case we
asked Twitter what like Isaac should get
tattooed on his head and we have a
winner there are a lot of colorful
responses probably over a hundred
something like that moon tower
underscore ATL I'm assuming this person
lives in Atlanta you're our winner Mike
Isaac should get his own face including
his glasses and his beard tattooed on
the back of his head I think that's
awesome
I could be basically watching you at all
times like like you know you should feel
that I am or something like that so moon
tower congratulations you get the new
iPhone case I'm not going to tattoo that
my face on on the
back of my face ah shucks sorry that was
the deal Mike will get to pick right he
did what we did not do with the case
whether he keeps the case and eaten he
gets the tattoo or you get the case and
he does not become tattoo so so I like
that I like that giveaway I think we all
lose continues our ETL you win then
continue thinking of tattoo suggestions
for me it may be for you something maybe
you'll get yeah right party at the moon
tower anyway that's all for this week
we'll be back next week with more phones
more gadgets board to comically enormous
smartphones with styluses styling boards
on the gadget lab until then
[Applause]